[Musique]
samedi c'est jimmy et je suis ravi de
vous retrouver pour notre rendez-vous
voyage sur la première dès fois on parle
très très loin d'autres fois un petit
peu moins aujourd'hui je vous emmène à
toulouse on part et retrouver un
martiniquais qui s'appelle aymeric team
irs son nom ne vous dit peut-être rien
en revanche sa musique vous la
connaissez forcément rencontre avec le
mger
[Musique]
salut aymeric celle qui on est à
toulouse avec toi aujourd'hui comment ça
va à toulouse je sais pas si vous êtes
en zone verte hors zone rouge par
rapport déconfinement donc ça commence à
aller on peut déjà circulé plus ou moins
si on voulait prendre de tes nouvelles à
savoir comment ça allait alors pour bien
expliquer qui tuer parce que lesdits
aymeric monde connaît peut-être plus tôt
sous le m
alors pour bien expliquer je propose
qu'on regarde justement une vidéo comme
ça tout le monde verra de qui je parle
pour ceux qui ne connaissent pas vite je
vais tout péter fait pour situer parce
qu'il ya plein de gens qui connaissent
la chanson forcément qu'ils ont chanté
pendant le carnaval et toute cette
histoire qui se remettent bien c'est
donc toi aymeric qui est à l'initiative
de cette chanson on en parle un petit
peu comment ça a démarré cette histoire
parce que cette chanson est quand même
folle c'est celle qu'on a entonné
pendant tout le carnaval quand on est
encore en soirée que ça devient un peu
festif
c'est cette chanson là qui revient ces
parties de quoi du 1017 ya un mois
alexis main ulissi et non les tirs
étaient en fait ils organisent ils
organisaient pour des affiches et du cou
et du coup fait là c'était la période
carnavalesque et ce soit et il ya des
gens qui
filmée du coup d'après il ya eu une
vidéo sur facebook et fait plus de
cinquante milles en 24 heures et du
boulot les gars m'ont dit qu'il fallait
au studio et tout faut qu'on aille au
studio et du coup une semaine après mais
giteau studio le vendredi et j'ai posé
sa chedid gestion et tours et puis on
n'a pas dit si le son habit et de
l'accueil cette leva dernier van hamme
est ce que tu bosses sur sur d'autres
projets musicaux en ce moment oui demain
jusqu'à mon boulot - subit lien est fait
j'étais bloqué plusieurs fois après ses
revers en fait beau mais tout est en
fait 8 passes trop disponible pour je
peux pas à le situer tout et vous l'avez
même si comme avait limité au niveau des
sorties mais ouais je pense qu'il nous
faudra un bon son de vacances là quand
on sera sorti du colis de 19 pour bien
se défouler et je pense que c'est la
bonne personne pour nous sortir un hit à
nouveau en tout cas on espère que tu vas
arriver à trouver le temps pour bosser
parce que comme tu disais c'est pas
évident de concilier les deux notamment
avec avec ton travail de militaire
d'ailleurs il ya eu le carnaval aux
antilles on a eu le champ le temps par
an et la chance d'avoir ce carnaval par
contre est allé carnaval du côté
toulouse de bordeaux qui ont été
annulées cette année tu n'as pas pu les
faire tu avais peut-être prévu peut-être
des prestations d'être sur scène ça n'a
pas pu se faire
en fait j'ai eu mon diplôme en aval de
montpellier après malheureusement à
cause du confinement mais du coup les
deux autres celui de toulouse et de
bordeaux bezos staut est en fait de
bâches de fontès sortir des sons pour le
carnaval
mais en fait c'est à dire autre chose
donc j'ai pas vu ben écoute nous on
espère en tout cas que qu'on aura la
chance d'avoir ce sont ce sont des
vacances est ce que tu vas travailler
que la même équipe si jamais tu youtube
prépare quelque chose
après je suis un ami ou un ligne et du
coup voilà pas les nôtres
en fait c'est walid qui m'a donné le
contact de notre pique niqueurs et tu
couvres j'avais avant de terminer si tu
veux passer un petit message aux gens
que tu connais en martinique 1 déjà
joués
ça lui même qui en en tunique ma famille
aussi
et puis il ya aussi les comics place on
y arrive et sociales au dealer et puis
bon bah écoute le message est passé
merci à toi en tout cas aymeric prends
soin de toi et à très vite la prison
j'en profite pour saluer tous les
antillais qui se trouve à toulouse ou à
bordeaux qui nous regardent
régulièrement via le net
merci à vous de nous avoir suivi on se
retrouve très vite pour une nouvelle
rencontre sur la première
[Musique]